digamos que el día 1
es hoy y el día 1 es lunes
y yo quisiera saber
en qué día cae el día 300
en qué día de la semana cae el día 300
así que primero voy a escribir los días
de la semana voy a hacer esta cuadrícula
de esta manera ya tenemos el lunes
tenemos el martes tenemos el miércoles
el jueves
el sábado
y después voy a rellenar con los números
en sí voy a poner aquí el 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
8 9 10 11 12 podría seguir y seguir
15 pero bueno fue hasta el 16 podemos
observar que hice esta cuadrícula y que
la cuadrícula tiene 7 columnas
pues bien corresponden a los días de la
semana y utilizando esta cuadrícula
podré saber un día con algún número por
ejemplo aquí el 16 el día 16 es martes
pero para números grandes esto no tiene
sentido o sea tanto para el día 300 como
para el día 3000 no tiene sentido tratar
de ubicarlos poniendo números en la
cuadrícula por lo que me gustaría saber
si puedo encontrar un método matemático
por el cual yo pudiera saber en qué día
de la semana cae cualquier número que yo
quiera entonces se me ocurren lo
siguiente veamos para el caso del 16 qué
tal si yo hiciera esto
a ver voy a mover tantito mi pantalla no
qué tal si yo propongo que la idea es
tomar el número que estamos interesados
en este caso es el 16 dividirlo entre 7
y 16 entre 7 es exactamente es igual a 2
porque 2 por 7 son 14 y tengo un residuo
de 2
lo que estoy encontrando el 16 tiene dos
renglones completos de siete números
y este que tengo aquí
y luego tengo un residuo de dos y aquí
la información importante me la está
proporcionando el residuo porque me está
diciendo que en el renglón en el que él
se encuentra que en este caso es el
tercer renglón en la segunda posición es
la segunda columna y entonces
efectivamente como habíamos visto el 16
es martes y parece que funciona claro lo
que acabamos de hacer me dice que tengo
dos renglones completos de siete y el
residuo es la segunda columna que es
esta que está aquí y ya vimos que es
martes
hagamos lo mismo ahora para auto número
digamos para el día que te parece el día
25 a ver vamos vamos vamos a poner el 25
y otra vez voy a hacer primero mi mi
cuenta haciendo un poco más despacio
porque me estoy quedando corto de
espacio entonces a ver vamos a ponerlo
y así
vamos a ver el 25
/ / 7
bueno pues hagamos la división entonces
pongo el 25 el 7 afuera el 7 cabe tres
veces en el 25 3 por 7 21
lo pongo aquí ahora lo voy a restar 21
para 25 es 4 y entonces ya tengo cabe
tres veces y tengo un residuo de 4 esto
me dice que es de 3 veces y tengo un
residuo de 4 o sea como lo habíamos
visto van a ser tres renglones completos
y la columna número cuatro por lo que
todo empiece a indicar que el 25
es jueves porque está en la columna 4 a
ver vamos a ver si es cierto vamos a
rellenar los números que faltan en
nuestra cuadrícula entonces tendremos el
17 el 18 el 19 20 21 22 23 24 y
magnífico el 25 está en la cuarta
columna y es un jueves perfecto creo que
ya tenemos un método matemático para
saber qué día de la semana es un número
determinado y regresamos a nuestro
problema original del 300 entonces a ver
voy a reacomodar otra vez la pantalla
entonces esto es lo que tenía
estamos
vivamente y entonces ahora lo que vamos
a hacer al 300 lo vamos a dividir entre
7 entonces a ver vamos a hacerlo por acá
este a ver puede ser un poco de espacio
porque se me hace que no va a caber ni
división entonces a ver vamos a poner a
300 lo voy a dividir entre 7
entonces
7 cabe cuatro veces en 34 por 720 8
ahora lo voy a restar entonces
28 para 30 son 2
el 0
ahora el 7 en el 20 cabe dos veces 27 14
ahora hago la diferencia y 14 para 20
son 6 por lo que el día 300 estará en la
columna número 6 y
así que lo logramos el día 300 es